so when i was a lead at the beginning i
was just controlling you know i just
said right do it this way this is how
you got to do it yeah i wasn't really
allowing anyone any opportunity to
innovate themselves or flourish that's
very directive i think it's just down to
the planning which is don't just look at
what's on your desk right now think
about what's going to be on your desk in
a couple of months time but again what's
the most you know it comes down to
prioritization what's the most important
thing it's developing people and it's
and it's really new business welcome to
the recruitment mentors podcast on this
week's episode i was joined by paul
church paul has worked in recruitment
for 14 years and for the first 11 of
those he climbed the ranks within a
brand called sphinx and then for the
last couple of years he's been the
managing director for interquest and
more recently started his own
recruitment business called the anemo
group if you are someone that wants to
be a top performer a successful contract
recruiter you're gonna love this episode
and we also really dug deep into how
paul's gone about building communities
and talent pools
in his markets enjoy the episode paul
church welcome to the podcast good to be
here mate how you doing i'm good thanks
for coming to the space what do you
think podcast goals right here
obviously you've been doing your own
podcast so um yeah hopefully i mean i
definitely didn't start it here uh
started in my bedroom on on a mobile
phone so hopefully no doubt you'll have
your own poor class studios space soon
one day i'll be in the dream factory
um so where we always like to start this
podcast is
just just probably something that you
thought a lot about with your journey
hiring a lot of people managing people
so would love to hear your take on
like what do you believe are the
characteristics and traits that really
make up a high performing recruiter in
today's market let's start there yeah
it's a great question i think it's it's
changed a lot yeah over the years
certainly since i first got into
recruitment i think now you need a lot
more substance um i think you need a
real appetite
to become an expert in your market you
know the data generalists are long long
gone um so you really got to know your
stuff because you've got to be able to
contribute to the communities you work
in and add value to the to the clients
you've got the candidates you've got and
really stand out so it's not about gift
of the gab anymore certainly not it's
about
really wanting to be
an expert on your market
and that takes a certain type of person
need a intellectual aptitude of course
um just an appetite to be the best i
love it you use that word community
there
did that word get chucked around a lot
when you started your career no
absolutely no no no no not at all let's
get on the phones get on the phone to
get on the phones uh community was
something uh that came along um i think
and what i think i realized just by
accident if i built this community or
ecosystem and i owned uh the i owned
that i had access to who the clients
were who the candidates were and they
knew me that's what i wanted and so
community came from that for me well
just just on this really quickly just
interested like what what do you think
of the main sort of different mindset
shifts when you think about
my market over
serving the community i mean what do you
think of the if i'm a recruit right now
that still sees it as like it's my
market that's how i'm approaching it
over i'm building my community that i
can help support serve doing the same
job but i don't know what do you think
of the if someone's like my market over
community what do you think of the sort
of differences in
on the mindset piece or like how they're
approaching things thinking about things
i think community for me is about giving
something back and certainly giving
something back first and if you do the
right things i believe the right things
happen and i think recruitment typically
is seen as an industry
um that's something that takes from the
market it works rather it gives
something back so you can stand up quite
easily by actually actually contributing
in a positive way be it by bringing
people together be it by sharing
information or data so i think it's
about giving something back first yeah
like that given more than you take i
think the funny thing is right some
people think well like does that mean
you won't be able to achieve your goals
and won't be able to get as much out of
your market community as much as you
think but actually it's
i don't know we're going to go into how
you found it but actually what i've
found is the actual more that you give
you the more it comes around
and the more opportunities you get in
these things absolutely and i think
you've got to make sure you tread the
balance right and you
know when to
to sell as well you've got to know when
to sell because if you just build this
great community but you don't ask for
anything you don't try and get anything
from it then yeah you know you've built
build if nothing but
i think it's about um getting the
balance right between the commercial and
uh and the authenticity love that so a
lot that we can go into but i guess just
to frame it up obviously
started your career with a business
where you ended up working there for
about 11 or so years
so we'll talk a bit about that and and
your journey and progression your career
and then went into an md position which
you're still involved in now and then
more recently
started your own recruitment business as
well yeah so i guess let's just start
then i guess like
who who was pulled before recruitment
out of interest paul was on the dole
before the program really yeah paul was
lost uh didn't have a clue um i got a
decent degree and i worked in tv
production for a little while okay got
ended up losing my job sat on the door
for three or four months um and i didn't
really yeah i didn't really know what i
was gonna do and it wasn't i didn't have
any burning ambition to to make loads of
money but i needed to make some money
and recruitment just kept popping up and
popping up i thought i'll give it a go
yeah so yeah i was completely completely
lost in know what i was going to do
myself so how old was you russell do you
remember 22 really wow
quite daunting
especially when you went to uni and then
you're like what the hell am i going to
do yeah and in hindsight you like anyone
picked my degree which is journalism
didn't realize that it was gonna be
really hard to earn any money from it
yeah did get a job in it then lost my
job and then couldn't find another job
in it i was like what i've been doing
myself last four years whatever waste so
when you so when you
sort of it was mortimer sphinx right
that you joined so when you joined there
did you is it fair to say did you have a
bit of chip in your shoulder then that
you had a bit of a like right i need to
make this work or what was the mindset
early on i think early on i was didn't
really still didn't know what i wanted
to do and i was just a bit probably a
bit annoyed that i was having to go and
work in recruitment i couldn't find
anything else and i think the chip in my
shoulder came after my first three
months when they didn't want to keep me
really
they weren't going to pass my probation
i really kind of dug my heels in because
i thought right if i lose my job here
then that's the second thing that's you
know not working where where do i go
support no keep me and then then i had
to chip in my shoulder a few months fit
why didn't they want to keep you because
i wasn't applying myself i wasn't really
i wasn't committed to it i was there
because i i needed to earn a bit of
money but i actually wanted to do the
job and if you're not all in on
recruitment and you're not going to work
with it so they didn't see anything
positive so what did you say then you're
like no look i am going to change this
is a job that i want like what was the
sell i just said i said look i am
committed to making this work
i'm not failing again it's kind of what
i said and luckily my boss at the time
he he gave me that shot and uh it worked
out i love that so what what do you
think a career recruitment has given me
that maybe you least expected money
money definitely i've never been i was
never that money driven at all um when i
was younger and i thought i need to earn
loads of data yeah um so certainly has
given me money and for me money is not
about buying loads of expensive things
but it's been really it's allowed me to
have options and do things i wanted to
do you know i'm never gonna wear a rolex
or anything like that and we're a
fitness tracker probably more right
uh but it's given me money and it also
it taught me um i think it showed me how
competitive i really was as well um and
how goal-oriented i actually was if i
had a goal in front of me um so show me
that i love that and i'm assuming as
well coming from
that journey and maybe it's also being
able to show you what you're capable of
yeah if you went if you think of when
looking back like i didn't really know
what i wanted to do but now it's like
wow [ __ ] i've been able to achieve
these things or progress in my career
because it's competitive externally as
well as internally 100 and it's um it's
a shame that everyone falls into
recruitment and no one actually grows up
wanting to do it because it's it's
amazing you know
it changes your life well hopefully we
can change that
absolutely absolutely the thing is it is
such a great career choice and
regardless if you stay in it or not i
think the transferable skills
like are so valuable if i think of what
it helped me i think it helped so many
people their confidence
just inner confidence which a lot of
people would love to have more of and
then just the transferable skills of
being able to build relationships
commercial awareness
i think it can help a lot of people yeah
um
so i guess what i always like to ask
then sort of know what we know knowing
what you know now what advice would you
give paul sort of starting out in
recruitment a lot of people listen to
this that are starting their careers so
what advice would you give younger paul
going into industry yeah i think
assuming you've joined the right
business and you're with the right
people is just to trust them that
they've been there and done it and i
think it's until you actually hit that
that next level of success it's
so hard to imagine what it's going to be
like and i probably spent a lot of you
know had a lot of sleepless nights
thinking what i was doing wasn't working
and i'm just desperate for it to click
and my boss kept reassuring me that if i
did the right things it would work out
and i was
i think i probably was really hard on
myself at that time and if i had just
trusted the process the process and the
people around me who had been successful
before me that it was going to work i
probably would have been happier i'd say
i had that
how long did i how like i know we're
going back quite a bit here but like if
you remember how how long did it take
for you to then stop thinking no
actually like starting to happen now
like because i think that's good for
people to hear how long sometimes it can
take yeah i mean for me it was pretty 18
months really i mean it was 2008 so yeah
we had no jobs uh we were more
marketplace then it was what was it okay
you know it needs good 19 needs mr mrs
clinton
yeah and then we evolved into actually
being experts in what we were doing
right needed to find a market but yeah
it took 18 months or so so it was a long
slogan i think the challenge now is it's
different because now you can get quite
quick you get interesting gratification
because everyone's got so many jobs on
yeah money quite quickly but then the
challenge will come when the market
changes again
so if i'm listening to this and i'm
struggling right now hopefully they're
not but i guess what what are some of
the because i'm sure you've had this
you've you've ended up saying the same
things to people that you've mentored um
being managers of like what are the sort
of things that people should be looking
at to go no you know what like i did
that today or this week that happened
that should mean hopefully i'm on the
right track you know i mean what are
some of the key sort of indicators to go
you know what if i keep doing this and i
keep experiencing the those moments and
hopefully it should start clicking if
that makes sense
it's quite common so i had this advice
where your manager said to you paul keep
doing what you're doing yeah and it'll
pay off yeah so i guess what i'm trying
to ask you is from what you see now what
are those things that people need to
keep doing if you get what i mean so if
i'm listening to this and i'm struggling
what from your perspective what are the
things that i need to keep doing day in
day out that hopefully would mean over a
period of time it will really start
paying off yeah i think we had a chat
about this in integration i think it's
about short-term media and term
long-term okay and so the short term is
the jobs on your table that's what
people typically just tend to look at
and tend to work yeah you've got to
start thinking about the median term
which is okay how do i those clients i'm
working with how do i get into them more
how do i expand them and in long term
the clients you don't even know yet what
am i doing around that um so am i
putting out
my brand what are people recognizing
what i'm the best at what i'm saying i'm
the best at at least am i making
creating events am i posting things on
social media so i think it's just down
to the planning which is don't just look
at what's on your desk right now think
about what's going to be on your desk in
a couple of months time no i like that
because it's so easy to look at just
what's in front of you yeah isn't it and
we were i think we we phrased it as the
fight the battle and the war fight
battle of war you need all of them i
love that
so let's talk a bit about this sort of
11 or
11 year journey then because what what
i'd really be keen to sort of get your
thoughts and experiences on is
that sort of pull the recruiter to then
pull the leader because a lot of people
struggle with that and a lot of people
aspire to be a leader so i guess firstly
what if you think of where you started
nearly didn't pass your probation like
what besides work hard applying yourself
why was paul then able to get those
promotions which no doubt people sitting
next to you were going for as well
yeah i think i mean
initially it was certainly because i did
something different which was created a
brand which i was the first to do that
in in sphinx then we tried to roll it
out a little bit more after that um what
does that mean creating a brush so
building a market specific market rather
than absolutely generalist yeah
there was a content management system
called drupal yeah written in php so i
recognized there was a short there was a
good balance of the shortage of people
out there and high demand yeah but
enough if i knew everyone and i knew who
the clients were i could i could make
some money from it so got to know all
the drupal developers became the drupal
recruiter and put myself out there like
that so that was one of the key things i
think
but it was just just it was just all
down to numbers so in terms of getting
promoted to a team leader yeah just down
the street
in recruitment it doesn't matter if i
could make a good lead or not you get
promoted anyway don't you yeah and then
you then you have to learn as you go and
it's interesting right so on because
niche is really common now isn't that
so like what
what is what is i don't know i'm always
interested in people's perspective like
what makes a niche a good niche or like
what like some people think is am i too
niche am i too general do you know what
i mean like what is the key sort of
principles that you look forward to you
know what that could be a really good
niche and there's enough there it's
enough to sort of make enough money from
or maybe actually no it's maybe not big
enough do you know what i mean what how
do you think about that yeah it's tough
i mean it probably it probably is a
magic number formula i don't know
exactly what it is you've got to have
the right balance of there could be
enough people but not too many if a
client could put an advert out and get
loads of them through on their on their
advert yeah that's the wrong market
because it's too saturated with
candidates so it's got to be fairly hard
to find they can't be in such shortage
that you know it's not be worth your
time at all yeah just getting the
balance right between supply and demand
okay
so like you said got there on
performance so what what we found
particularly uh recruitment mentors like
you just said you get their merit to get
their own performance and a lot of the
time you don't get a whole lot of
support on how how does paul become a
better leader typically you have to be a
pretty [ __ ] once become a good one
so what were some of those challenges
early on on that leadership journey
where you're no longer just focused on
your own number your own performance
your then response for other people's
performance what were some of the early
challenges do you think um certainly i
think you know we talked about all the
time that you know the billing team
leader is the toughest position yeah and
it's about you have to learn to let go
of certain things both in terms of
financially you think well i can make
money out of this myself
but you're probably better off actually
enabling someone in your team to make
money for themselves as well um so that
that's that's a tough transition i think
um
it can be it's difficult to stop i mean
what certainly when i was a lead at the
beginning i was just controlling you
know right do it this way this is how
you got to do it yeah i wasn't really
allowing anyone any opportunity to
innovate themselves or flourish i just
wanted some i was very directive why was
that because you you just knew what
worked for you so you're like i'd rather
just just do what i've done because it's
you think it's just an easier way to get
to success yeah and i think i didn't
know how to manage probably didn't have
a lead properly i knew my way worked so
that's that's what i'm going to roll out
of everyone and they're going to have to
do it that way and that's really common
but like so i guess someone that might
be listening to this right now that
might have that approach what would you
say to them to think about to get them
to think about
maybe yeah if it isn't just do this
because it worked for me
like what what would be the what would
the advice be for those who are going
through that transition that may have
might have that leadership mindset i
think now more than ever people don't
want that approach i think people will
respond certainly the younger
generations coming through respond less
to that people wouldn't want the ability
to innovate themselves and do things
their own way i think you need to create
the boundaries around what what
shouldn't shouldn't happen but i think
people need to be able to find their own
way hmm
how do you go about finding that what
that way is
by trying things testing things being
allowed to fail you know trying things
out seeing what works what doesn't i
mean obviously it's all time critical
time critical trying to get deals in
yeah but they've got to explore and find
out the way that works for them yeah i
like that so yeah enabling them and
making it a safe place to fail
and like but then obviously there's a
bit of a balance of life if they keep
doing the same thing and failing then
it's like what we're going to change
here and those things but making sure
people are aware that they can try
things and it's okay to fail exactly
love that what about what would you say
so we were speaking about the the
billing leader piece what would you say
a lot of people listen to this will be
wanted to be a director one day um may
even be
spoken to about about achieving an mbo
and on that journey what would you say
that the main difference is when it
comes to being a billing manager leader
compared to then paul being a director
what would you say the main difference
is yeah for me i think um
when you get to kind of direct a level i
think what you should be your focus is
should be two things bringing new
business in to your company to enable
others and then developing people kind
of desk side or collectively i don't
think um that kind of level should be
focused on candidates i also think one
of the one of the things that mistakes
that leaders make as they got
recruitment is they stopped doing the
new business you know they stopped
trying to win companies uh win new logos
and when you cut a company's firm when
your clients in uh and i think that
that's why you think that's important to
like to keep your hand in that you've
got to add your value and an operational
leader i think is one who will be when
the tough kind of times come as we've
seen a couple years ago the ones who
won't survive yeah you've got to be able
to always say well i've brought this in
you know this is what i'm paying at
least my own salary here as well as
developing these other people and i
think as well if you stop doing it how
can you inspire others to do it as well
that's a good point how how did you
carve out time to do that then because
i'm sure a lot of people will will think
their time poor is willingly to let
alone the director and all the the
people management you've got to get
involved and you've got pnls to look at
you loads like you've got to manage
managers
how do you always carve out time to do
that i think i think as you go up for me
i don't think you should be doing the
resourcing side and that could be the
most time
time um time extended thing you could do
so once you take that out but again
what's the most you know it comes down
to prioritization what's the most
important thing it's developing people
and it's and it's winning new business
of course you've got to spend time doing
you know strategy and things like that
what you do need to do and going over
spreadsheets and p l's and things like
that but you've got to you've got to fit
them in as being not the most critical
things for your for your job the most
critical things your job are to lead by
example win your clients and develop
your people
managing managers what's that like
uh it's a different ballgame right yeah
again it's diff it's difficult and i
think um you need to make sure
particularly with managers you allow
them to run teams how they want to run
them again if you're directing your
manager how to direct his people what's
the point you know it does it does
happen so i think you need to be
comfortable that you know you're almost
outsourcing this team and this this
challenge this problem to your manager
and you've got to let them take that
problem away and do it do it the way
they're going to do it and you've got to
let them fail as well going and make
them that allow them the time to learn
from their mistakes as well
so
obviously it's really interesting you
said around the importance of like yeah
remaining in the game business
development so let's just sort of zoom
in on that a second like a really common
i'm sure you've seen this obviously it
is there's definitely like a big shift
going on in terms of like speak to lot
recruitment companies now that have
delivery functions and that they have a
plotted career path where if paul wants
to stay in delivery just focusing on the
candidate side then he can do that
whereas typically it was always
typically like a 360 where you're doing
client and candidate but
a lot of people struggle with that
transition where they might start on the
candidate side then they've been
expected to bring in their own clients
like what what do you think are the the
main principles to do and bd well in
today's market do you think because i
think a lot of people right now i from
the conversation that we're having i
don't know like could be getting
complacent right now with sort of how
stroke like easy it might be to win jobs
but like what what do you think of the
the fundamentals and principles behind
them business development really well in
today's market yeah i mean again yeah it
is tough for people coming into
recruiting right now um
they must think this is so easy this job
is the force accommodation
it is a voice comment and it will change
again you know we will come back to the
hard times again we've been talking
about this week that um there will be a
time when the clients don't necessarily
want to just be handing a load of jobs
and retainers and all this kind of stuff
so if you haven't come up in that how do
you adapt it's tougher to adapt to
revert to that that needs to be to to
learn that as you as you're coming up so
i think i think most importantly is at
this time i'd say it's important that
you're looking at the companies already
in your network yeah and maybe already
you're doing delivery for and looking at
how you can expand them and get them
really sticky to them so when the tough
times come you can reach out to them a
bit further on but again it goes back to
that short term median term long term
planning you know what are you doing to
get your brand out there yeah and you do
need a brand even if you're just doing
even if you're just doing delivery
you're probably doing delivery on one
particular market your java.net whatever
it may be so
it's important you're building that
brand out and that should stick with you
when you need to win a new business
later on as well where where do people
start if they've recognized five of
their clients could be clients that go
from spending 100 to 200 300
grand with them like where where where
have you typically started like
obviously like you said you've got short
term medium long term but if i'm
listening to this right now you know
what i know there i know this client
there's more that we could be doing with
them and there's three or four clients
that i i feel like have more jobs that
we could get but we're not quite getting
them yet like what are the sort of first
steps to getting towards getting those
yeah for me a lot of the time these
clients don't quite understand exactly
what else we do you know they only know
that we'll have that one relationship
with that one consultant who's
delivering one element to them yeah so
how do you get in front of the people so
again it goes back one thing we i've
done quite successfully and we do
interquest quite well is we we present
data to the key people in the businesses
we put together reports every few months
around what's going on in the market the
economy
and then we share with our clients we
say right let's get in front of whoever
this might be relevant to to help you
with your budgets your planning we get
in front of them present the data they
get some value from it at the end we say
oh by the way we do this you know we've
actually got an outsourcing model we've
also got a consultancy we also have a
finance division so how about is there
anything else we could help with and
just by telling them actually we do this
as well that can sometimes be enough
yeah because they don't because they
don't know i love that yeah so yeah just
leading with we've done a great job here
did you know that also we've been
helping other companies with this with
that we've got these functions
and like you said if you're even then
going to step further we're going this
is data this is information that could
be useful for you and by the way we've
got these functions that can support in
those areas can lead to good
conversations exactly so let's talk
about
sort of interquesting because what i'd
be really interested just to hear is
what what's paul's mindset go because
you went in as an md right
so obviously you was director of
multiple multimisting before he left
so like what what's the mindset going
into a role like that because i think
typically
like and i'm assuming here it would be
easier to be a director in a company
that you've like worked your way up in
and you've sort of gained your strikes
people yeah paul was it was an unreal
biller you've got that credibility do
you know what i mean so what was the
mindset going into a role like that to
make sure that you wasn't that md that
came in and just sort of said right
we're doing it this way the way you've
been doing it is wrong do you know what
i mean what was the mindset out of
interest yeah i mean it was tough
because you're kind of institutionalized
by great company in sphinx
you've come up through that and actually
the mentality of sphinx was always to
bring in people from the ground up so
everyone's come up with that sphinx way
which is great for me but at the same
time i'm going into quintequest which is
a brand new business people don't know
me and you start thinking how good am i
i don't know
i don't actually know i don't mean i've
never been anywhere else i don't know
how good yeah yeah yeah
and i think for me the most important
thing was to sit down meet everybody and
listen to everybody and spend about you
know two or three weeks at least just
getting to understand the business
before i started to come in and give any
kind of directive at all um and i
realized there was something there are
some fantastic people in interquest who
had actually come from all different
sorts of backgrounds so i learned i knew
well i can i'm gonna learn a lot from
these people as well yeah i love that
how did you deal with like you said i
think that'd be really common for people
listening that might be considering a
quite senior move but
like you said a lot of people have sort
of really gained their strikes from one
company and like yes you can do
recruitment but how different is it
going to be in this company how did you
deal with that maybe that self-doubt
that you might have had i was lucky
because the uh md sorry the co at the
time he'd actually worked with me at
spencer okay he was an interquest and he
kind of brought me in so i had half a
half a foot in the door and he and he
was like you're gonna be fine here yeah
i had that reassurance um i think it's
just about coming into being humble and
about being confident as well being
humble what you need to learn and exp
understand you're gonna love other
people as well yeah um but you know if
you've got if you've done well in
recruitment at one place you're going to
be able to do well somewhere else as
well yeah and it's all about you know
it's all about results if you've got
results in one place there'll be
something you can add um so what are
some of the challenges that you're
facing in that first year in that role
do you think um i think we there there
was um i think what i had to focus on
was
helping people be a bit more
collaborative
there were a couple of brands within the
business which i was looking after which
didn't necessarily work together and it
was those opportunities to cross over
and help each other and even the company
the brands that i looked after they
didn't really interact with each other
so they've kind of brought them all
together now they're actually really
together and they're all just kind of
one big group um so there was a lot of
missed opportunities and also it was
fairly uh at that point we was a little
bit reactive sitting on some big
accounts and it was probably needed to
be a bit more of a new business acumen
which we worked on and we've got them
there hey everyone a real quick one from
me this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincerie and sauce breaker because you
listened to this podcast you were able
to get your hands on exclusive savings
on both of these award-winning products
if you're all a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincerie
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your growing recruitment business
with sourcebreaker if you want to make
sure that all of your recruiters have
the best tools on the market to stand
out and beat their competition then you
have to check out sourcebreaker use the
link in the show notes in the comments
below and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products
where do you start i think that's such
an interesting challenge isn't it like
where
because it's competitive like i said
internally and externally so where where
do you where do you even start in
attempting to get people to collaborate
more when historically there might have
been like no this is our patch this is
what we do like i want to make sure we
like build as much as we can rather than
thinking about paul's team that could
also benefit where'd you even start i'm
not trying to get them to feel that way
i mean first thing is getting them all
out together and enjoying themselves
together and getting to know each other
and actually talking around what what
what they're doing together um i started
just little things like making sure
everyone had visibility over who was
working with who like sharing on emails
all the clients
and the roles we had and what was going
on so everyone had visibility in what
was going on bringing everyone into
meetings together yeah um but it's
really just about getting people to
interact more together and just kind of
sit down and say did you set any like
sort of not rules but you know what i
mean because there's nothing more worse
than going pool [ __ ] nick my
candidate at that time i'm not do you
know what i mean because some of that
can go on i don't know if even part of
that process was like these are the sort
of non-negotiables or this is how we
work collaboratively or i don't know did
you have to do any of that we certainly
sold the benefit of cross-selling you
know there's opportunities here with
clients we've got and these other brands
in the business you're going to do a 70
30 split it makes sense it's a
no-brainer so you're always going to you
should be able to make money more money
together than separately so um so yeah
typically that by selling the benefit of
that that was generally enough so how
yeah because i know people would run on
that so how did you typically
incentivize things then so it was you
said 1750 split as in
so the team they've got typically the
relationship but then they've gone oh
they've said that they need help with
this but we typically don't do that what
they would get 70 percent and the other
team would get 30 or how would it i know
it's nuanced but the delivery person
would get 70 percent right and the
person whose client is going up they get
30 percent nice
um
i love that so
in terms of when when did when did the
community piece start then like when did
because i think that's when we first
connected
i think it was during um
i think it was proper during clover
vibes no like i think like i saw you
doing things around mental health you're
bringing people together you're doing
webinars like when did the this work
community start showing up more more
often in in your recruitment world yeah
i think well i think when i was a
consultant and i built a candidate
community community around drupal i was
calling that a community yeah yeah but
certainly with interquest i mean the
first lockdown when all you know clients
most of them stopped hiring we're just
like how do we stay on their radar how
do we give them something once they get
back up to speed and before they so when
they do start hiring they're going to
want to work with us
a lot of our clients are asking you know
what are businesses doing around this
and that um so i said right i'm going to
stop a webinar series each week um and
we're going to have an expert to talk
about a certain topic um so with the
first few ones were how to remote
interview yeah
on boards all these things are like
crazy
uh and then it just it just grew from
there and in the end i was thinking i
said i'm gonna do it every week and
before we go a bit deeper we can start
talking about mental well-being dei uh
culture and values evp and we've grown
that community which is called people
commun culture and tech which is under
the interquest brand of course uh it's
about a thousand members in our meeting
really yeah so i was so you started like
a meet-up
group and then people sign up there and
then they get notified of the events
that are going on exactly yeah and it's
been a webinar series which then last
year we brought it out as a podcast as
well love that so let obviously with
hindsight then
let's just talk because a lot i think a
lot of people like a modern day
recruiter will have this as part of
their business plan along with the other
sort of channels that i'll be using so
how and i know you're doing this now of
your own business but like how would you
like know what you know now how would
you go about starting that journey then
because it seems like obviously it's
quite reactive but you actually took
action i'm sure a lot of people had the
idea of doing what you did but didn't
[ __ ] take action on it so how would
you how would you go back now and like
start that over again and you know now
do you think what would be the the game
plan yeah i mean well i've done this
with uh talent and growth for the nemo
group really but i think it's about
firstly assessing who's your target
audience yes is it because you're trying
to is it candidates is it heads of
talent like perhaps it might be for
myself in the nemo group
and i think the best thing to do is get
in front of them and ask them what they
would like to see what would add value
to them so if you have a hundred
conversations with 100 heads of talent
that's firstly that's a hundred
conversations a hundred heads
who are then gonna hopefully like you
and engage with you further you're
getting the intel from them as to what
they'd like to see so don't just assume
anything use the opportunity to get in
front of people to discuss something
other than recruitment and have not been
not being transactional and actually
find out what they want i love that as
simple as that
so the key thing for you then is i'm
assuming if you really do the leg work
on that then whatever you decide to do
if it's
bringing people together to discuss
things or webinars on certain topics
it's just about making sure it's
something that people actually deem to
be valuable or useful or would want to
want to attend exactly so let's talk
about the because i know we've spoken
about this like okay so we've done that
we've really understood what people
would um really appreciate how like
would see his value how do we then make
sure like you said we're not doing it
just for community's sake like where
where can we make sure we're having that
commercial awareness to ask when
necessary like how how do you think
about that for people listening like
when when is the right time to say oh
when's the not right time to sell how do
you think about that i think once you've
built i think the challenge sometimes
people have is they're scared to make
that leap because they think well i've
built this
relationship based on the community or
being friends with them now i'm scared
to ask them to if i can work them in
this sense but my my answer that would
be they know what you do they know what
your job is you're not you know you're
not martin dressed as lamb you know
you know they know what your job is um
they would probably expect it at some
point anyway and you're asking them
because you because presumably you feel
like you're going to do a good job for
them because you're good at what you do
something's good to say listen you know
we like each other um i'm working with
you in this sense how about we help you
on these roles you're looking for yeah
yeah and that's typically how is that
typically being received because
obviously people can be worried about it
yeah i think look people people
that i've engaged with they'll either
say yes or no but it's certainly not you
know
they they're not shocked they're not you
know offended when i ask them you know
they're probably expecting it at some
point because they know i'm a
recruitment company but is is the
important part here that like for this
community piece
to work you need to lead with giving
more rather than taking yeah but at the
same time i think this will be spoken
with like you you've at the same time
you've got you've got ask and you've
gotta have a balance of not just doing
it for community sake yeah exactly i
think you've got to know you've got to
when those opportunities come up you
think actually there's there's something
there and i reckon i could help this
client you've got to make the leap and
just ask but if you've given something
good to the community first of all in
the form of podcast data information
then you know don't feel guilty so what
would you say like
going into this year now what would you
say the the things that you really learn
all seems like a bit of a blur to me but
like obviously you when you as a md and
still are
at interquest like throughout the whole
kobe period what are the main things
that have stayed with you do you think
that you're really taken into this year
and will continue to what the main
things that you learned do you think
during that period because i'm sure
would have been really difficult for you
from in the leadership role
i think nice
she's also questioning again yeah no
yeah of course so i guess what i'm just
curious to think now because i'm sure it
may just be natural to you now but
just curious to understand like that
whole kobe period when he was an md
like what are some of the key things
that you
learn during that period that really
stuck with you that you're gonna live by
every day
this year do you know what i mean yeah i
think um i think by continuously making
sure i'm making an effort to provide our
clients and our contacts with
information
from the bd side i think or from the
external side certainly um i think just
making sure i'm constantly out there
trying to help our clients and our
communities working
and we did i did that more than ever in
2020 and that's something i'll take with
me i love that so let's let's talk about
more recent times then so how how long
have you been into your own business
journey then so i started officially at
the beginning of november um the first
couple of months just on branding um
started running my own podcast for that
and then went live
first of january professor jan and then
what's the sort of niche that you're
focusing on so really it's it's an
embedded talent model so working as an
extension or as the internal talent
teams with businesses when they have um
specific hiring requirements or volume
recruitment so it's not the traditional
recruitment agency yeah so it's a
different self you know it's uh it's a
selling to uh it's it's just you know
you're asking companies to part with
money up front or commit to money
upfront it's completely different kind
of sales cycle and also with a brand new
client base because i'm going yeah it's
completely on my own and yeah
the clients i had before that are with
interquest which is cool yeah yeah
so let's just talk about this for a bit
because i'm sure you've seen that like
this is more and more common i feel like
talent partners
paul working with x company via
um interquest or whatever so
what what like
like you said it's a different cell what
are the what the main difference is
besides money up front like i don't know
because i think a lot of people using
this technology like solution selling
things like that like what what are some
of the things that maybe you've you've
had to like adapt to or get better at or
improve on when sort of selling a
solution like this i think it's about um
so i think the benefit of it is it's
becoming a partner with the client you
know and i think the old-fashioned
speculative cv model um is it's a long
way away from that so it's working in
partnership with clients it's about
talking about the other things we can
add value in terms of their processes
in terms of their structure in terms of
their candidate experience in terms of
their own boarding so it's going deeper
with clients so it's not just about
getting people through the door it's
actually working with them on their
brand and how to attract people into the
group love that and then what
like
what's and i'm sure this is a continued
process
but like what are some of the key things
that you look for
in companies or for companies to have
for you to go you know what a talent
partner model or an embedded solutions
model
should from what i can see should
potentially be a good fit like what the
key thing to look for is it that they're
hiring a lot of people is it there they
may only have one person in the people
functions you know i mean what are some
of the the key things that make you go
you know what that could be a good
company that maybe we could really help
with this type of solution i think
i think the ideal clients i think would
probably be the ones who maybe anything
between 10 to 30 people yeah they've got
some funding they haven't yet brought in
a talent team themselves they don't
necessarily want to or can afford to pay
the higher recruitment traditional fees
they don't really know how their process
should work internally because that's
ideal for you to go in and work them in
that sense uh and actually what we can
also do then is set them up with a
talent team for when we go as well so we
kind of roll them future proof of them
as well exactly um and then like how
have you
you don't have to go into like the exact
details but i know people be curious
like are you saying right you pay this
upfront over x period of time which is
the hiring project that we've agreed to
and then if you and then i know it's not
just about people but if you i don't
know if you then got a separate um fee
attached to like okay if we deliver on
five hires per month then you pay this
extra on top like how have you typical i
know you might still be playing around
with this but like have you typically
approached like pricing it out of
interest yeah i mean
we try and tailor it around what the
client is after but it could be um
on a subscription basis so we'll be
working with you you know five days a
week yeah every day uh over this month
and then we'll charge on a monthly basis
okay that looks like it'll be slas what
do they expect from us during that time
yeah which we can adhere to it might be
more that listen all we want you to do
is fill these roles here's five rolls um
and we'll price up what that would cost
yeah for us to fill it and i suppose
we're valuing really in that case the
commitment and the partnership more than
a percentage so yeah we could do a fair
bit cheaper but we know we're going to
be the ones who are going to feel lost
so on the slas i think that's again
something that people and i know this
will vary but what what what i've ended
up being like um and again this still
might be like a learning journey for you
but what what are typically the slas
that you've led with or have said like
this is what i know it's nuanced here
but i know people be interested because
that's quite a common question that i
get just like he should um i'm selling
this sort of mini rpo or we're going to
be an extension of their business like
what what what are people typically
agreeing to from like a delivery
standpoint because like you said it's
not just about bums on seats and people
so like what what have ended up being
the typical slas that you've ended up
speaking to people about of interest on
the deliverable deliverables yeah i
think um if you talk cv's scent is is
not enough because of course how is that
cv going to be so i think generally you
try and base it on and i've kind of
learned this from some of the guys at
interquest is that um
it's how many people have they actually
wanted to interview that you've sent
them so if you've got x amount of people
through through to interview stage that
they've been happy with that's probably
enough of an indication that you're on
the right lines with things yeah so
that's that's usually the sla we're
looking at
how's it going so far though it's going
okay it's going good i think it's uh
again i'm i'm starting from a brand new
client basically
and i'm selling a bigger cell so it's
been fascinating it's really really fun
um
but it's tough you know because i'm
building something from from nothing
with it uh but that's that's you know
that's just again what's been most
challenging that maybe at least expected
so far uh
working on my own yeah how's that been
um it's been tough and actually so
obviously we've been working home
largely even with interquest but you
know a couple of couple of days a week
where i'm not with interquest i'm
literally just working at home on my own
i've actually there's a couple of times
last week i think oh i've started to
feel a little bit down yeah i want to
get in a wee work of myself for a couple
of days a week so i think just that not
even someone to call to talk about what
we like yeah
because you've always had that because i
always had that and yeah you have good
days and bad days with it when when i
went to like a co-working space that
massively helped so you're gonna look to
do that yeah definitely just just a day
or so a week you know my girlfriend's
out of the house i'm literally in the
house of my own so i'm just like
normally buzz off at all it's uh you
don't i didn't recognize how much i
needed that yeah yeah and then how has
it been sort of um obviously working
with interwest and then your your own
piece as well how's that been yeah it's
i mean it's been i just feel really
fortunate with it really i really i
think that's i already respect that
because when you told me i don't i don't
know what how you feel but i feel like
if you would sit down
with one of your mates you worked some
recruitment down the pub and go yeah so
i'm i'm an md interquest in that
obviously part time then i'm also doing
my own thing yeah like people go really
yeah exactly and it's uh it's yeah it's
really refreshing of our ceo to kind of
take that approach yeah kind of you know
say this is the way to go it's uh i love
working with interquest i love working
with people there so it's really really
good for me
and really the model i'm selling isn't
really in line with any any anything
they're doing and certainly my target
audience probably becomes smaller than
they go after as well i mean in the
quest i'm going to be worried about
little old me anyway
my my new clients i think they'll be
just fine so yeah it's been good it's
been good so where where would you like
to see yourself in like if we're to be
sitting down this time next year then
like where would you like to see the
business yeah i mean i'd like to say
we've got um
i'd like to have at least
i don't know maybe 10 people working
with me
out at some of our clients um like to
have you know four to five solid clients
who are giving regular service to and
working on site with so just to just i
think the most importantly for me my
goal for the end of this year is to be
self-sufficient from that business um
and hopefully that's where i'll get yeah
absolutely and then what so like has the
main sort of the the difference because
a lot of people i feel like i don't know
how you feel when
they sort of go out and sort of start on
their own they really they're like we're
doing things differently
these things so you've got this
this
model that you're sending that's
different is that like the main thing
you're really leaning into so like this
is how we do things differently and
like as well that's something exciting
for maybe new people to to join and go
this is actually different the way that
we're selling what the solution is is
that the main thing you're leaning into
with the so with the clients with the
well yeah just in general because a lot
of people want when they start a
recruitment company they're like we're
going to do it differently in these
things so the main thing that you're
leading into is is that embedded talent
solution the talent partner
and that's what you're leaning into
there's a difference yeah 100 and i
think it's it it's um there's a lot of
flaws with the traditional recruitment
model as well i think um for one thing
you know if you're working recruitment
you can do the best job in the world and
not get rewarded for it which can be a
shame so i think i've looked at what i
perhaps don't like so much about the
recruitment industry um both from the
recruiters side and from the client side
what the clients get as well and i think
this model which is you know i'm not the
first one to do something yeah they're
doing it i think it looks like a
positive way to go and do you feel like
and i think you're continuing to find
this but when i've spoken to people that
have ended up doing that what they've
really liked
is what you sort of said really where
they're able to really influence and get
involved
with more than just hiring a couple of
people and actually
i don't know after a project or after
working with a company you can go you
know what well their process looked like
this before and now it's this like is
that something that i don't know that
you're gonna you you feel like you'll
get even more joy out of within the job
yeah and that's the thing really because
i think since i set up the people
culture and tech community with
interquest i've got really really kind
of fascinated and passionate about
company culture and what companies are
doing with their people and what things
they can do to look after people um so
i've gone really all in on that you know
i'm always reading stuff i'm always
learning about it i'm always wanting to
have a conversation to find out what a
company is doing differently and then if
i can share that and help another
company find its way out of that then
that'd be amazing yeah i love that so as
we come to the end then obviously you
told us about the the future we'd like
to see something i'm excited to to see
from afar
what would be your i guess just to hear
paul's take on my partner advice for
anyone listen to this that really want
to achieve their goals this year like
what would be your partner advice to
those listening that yeah i really want
to have a good year this year yeah
firstly work out what your goal is yeah
um you know again is that long-term
planning what do you actually want to
achieve
and is that monetary is that personal is
that about your brand so work out what
it is and then break it down you know
break it what do i need to do each month
what i need to do each week um i think
as well just really thinking about what
you can do differently you know they
probably are still in in this world more
bad recruiters than good ones absolutely
so how can you stand out what can you do
differently to make you be known as the
best person in that field
and take a chance
paul i love it thank you so much
pleasure thank you very much
legend cheers mate appreciate that thank
you so much for listening to the episode
i hope you got value from the
conversation and there was a number of
key takeaways so please don't forget to
like share and please do share your key
takeaways in the comments below if you
did have some and thanks for supporting
the show